Обласна лікарня Мечникова у Дніпрі.
Шоста вечора.
Зазвичай саме у цей час до приймального відділення найактивніше прибувають
карети швидкої з прифронтових зон.
Запоріжжя!
Зазвичай 90 відсотків пацієнтів тут - евакуйовані поранені військові.
Лише за цей день - вже понад два десятки - з Донеччини та Запоріжжя.
Поїхали в кабіночку!
Раз, два, три!
Андрієві - 39, вдома чекає дружина та двоє дітей, він - піхотинець ЗСУ.
Чоловіка терміново вивезли з Торського, що на Донеччині.
Під час мінометного обстрілу чоловіка зачепили уламки.
Взагалі ми мали піти від точки.
А поки доходили, нас підстрелили,
вибух був, уламки потрапили.
Ноги, руки, живіт.
Я більше постраждав, я врятував…побратима.
Доки Андрія везуть по коридору, лікарі нам пояснюють:
поспілкуватися з пораненими пацієнтами буде непросто,
бо у свідомості їх сюди привозять зрідка.
Не переживай! Все зараз буде! Не впадеш! Молодець!
Наша лікарня приймає найважчих.
Це десятки поранених, які надходять кожного дня і кожної ночі.
Оглядають нейрохірурги, травматолог.
Чи потребує пацієнт негайного оперативного втручання.
Щось болить?
На огляд і первинну допомогу для пораненого
- від кількох хвилин до півгодини.
У кожного з них - є свій номер, який записують на руці або клаптику простирадла.
Це для обліку, який за час повномасштабної війни вже налічує понад 20 тисяч.
Більше 20 тисяч.
Це тільки за останні 600 днів.
Це величезні цифри.
До нас надійшло більше двох тисяч хлопців, які втратили кінцівки.
Виконується до ста операцій кожного дня, щоб врятувати життя воїнам.
Всі реанімаційні відділення заповнені.
Ти будеш спати. Буде трубочка в роті, ти заснеш.
На етапах евакуації до стабпункту дуже багато часу проходить.
Гинуть м'язи на нижній кінцівці або на верхній.
Щоб врятувати йому життя, треба ампутувати ногу.
Віталію, який зараз на операційному столі,
вже ампутували половину ноги
- у запорізькій лікарні.
Втім, через велике навантаження ресурсів доглядати його далі там немає.
До того ж, почалися ускладнення - чоловіка доправили сюди
у тяжкому стані.
Саме мінно-вибухові травми найчастіше зустрічаються серед поранених.
І робота з ними - найскладніший досвід і для самих лікарів.
Найважче - бачити всі ці травми.
Дуже багато ампутацій, дуже багато молодих хлопців,
які вже інваліди з 23-25-річного віку.
Ну… Реально не вистачає часу!
Палати набиті військовими.
Всіх не встигаєш прооперувати в один день.
А треба брати всіх і вся!
У цих стінах, зізнаються працівники лікарні,
їм доводиться надавати ще й основну психологічну підтримку для бійців.
Щодня! Обов'язково треба підтримувати!
Вони ж нас захищають! Молодці!
Спочатку підірвався на міні. Потім дрон добивав.
Потім уже коли їхали в машині евакуації на стабілізаційний пункт,
прилетів дрон, і жінка-медик, яка мене рятувала, загинула.
Через дах прилетів дрон і дірку в спині таку зробив,
як сковорідочку. І все. Оля 200. А я доїхав.
Після операцій на найтяжчих поранених чекає перша ніч у реанімації.
На ранок - огляд ран і перша перев'язка.
- Йому боляче!
Біля трьох-чотирьох діб вони знаходяться у реанімаційному відділенні.
До стабілізації стану. До покращення показників.
Потім намагаємося переводити у профільні відділення.
У нас був дуже складний період:
з травня місяця вони надходили по серпень.
У такій кількості ми не отримували таких навантажень з 14-го року...
Саме через рекордне навантаження за кількістю поранених, серед яких і цивільні з прифронтових містечок
і сіл, лікарня Мечникова не в змозі лишати тут пацієнтів до повного,
а часом навіть і часткового одужання.
Їх усіх переводять до лікарень інших міст України.
Сьогодні з лікарні Мечникова до Києва евакуаційний бус
везе п'ятеро важких поранених та кілька стабільних військових-іноземців.
Для підтримання стану пацієнтів тут обладнана мобільна реанімація,
зокрема і система штучної вентиляції легень.
На підключення пацієнтів до систем у парамедиків півгодини,
зволікати не можна.
Ці фахівці - іноземці.
Керівник команди - німець Макс.
Він уже понад пів року евакуює військових між містами України
і навчає цього українських парамедиків.
Ця робота - це абсолютно не те, що у нас у Німеччині.
У нас немає таких пацієнтів, поранених військових.
Ми маємо бути готові, раптом щось станеться в дорозі.
У нас для цього є повне обладнання, досвідчений лікар.
В Україні небагато спеціалістів, які мають необхідну підготовку й обладнання
для перевезення таких пацієнтів.
Тож, ми почали спеціальний навчальний курс у Дніпрі
для ураїнських медиків, щоб навчити їх транспортувати поранених.
Іноземні партнери значною мірою допомагають лікарні Мечникова,
аби заклад міг безперервно приймати поранених:
це і сучасне реанімаційне обладнання, і медикаменти.
Однак потреби постійно зростають.
Зараз, коли наші хлопці йдуть у наступ,
на жаль, у нас більше стає поранених героїв.
Війна, вона така, як вона є: вона важка, жорстока…
Зараз для закладу і всього регіону, каже директор, важливо забезпечити реабілітаційні ресурси,
аби відновлювати захисників тут, у Дніпрі.
Відповідне відділення дозволило би повністю ставити на ноги
більше тисячі бійців на рік.